[Music]
in no-mercy news submitted by geo don't
drink that huh don't dreamed it drink it
this was supposed to help with the brain
function whatever they throw at that
[__] voice did you have like a burps
Tigers in a brutal video shows a man
getting attacked as he's holding his
four-year-old daughter oh [__]
fine animal another human being I'm
gonna be sad well we got to do this you
know what if we watch any violence and
you hear this this makes it better yeah
it makes it silly
so what his daughters say to the person
who attacked her it was her fault yeah I
think so
how can you attack someone holding a
baby easy if I'm starving
yeah um you know where if I'm like
malnourished and I need something to eat
or drink yeah they're holding a baby in
a Subway sandwich I'm still in that
thing no I'm so hungry a Subway sandwich
sounds good that it never sounds good
Patrick
so this took place at Colorado I'll show
you the CCTV footage that's that I
thought everybody out in Colorado or
stoners and you know stoners relax
so people are angry at everyone that's
fighting the only innocent person here
and the public eye is a little girl good
thing we didn't let her go so you'll see
here we go what is this what this is
holding his daughter you jackass let
drop the daughter and the world is long
gone Oh clearly the daughters take her
yeah she's like dad fight him dad find a
suck him up [__] him up daddy
oh why would you do why would you oh
it's people jumping the guy oh dude I'm
like let go of the little girl what are
you doing you know why they not be this
dude out while he's holding his daughter
so we don't know why they punch wait go
back real quick
sucker punch it well they're still
punching out there's a jump in his ass
even me ham and [__] whoa so they're a
bunch of [__] dude yeah they are
wait let me line up the mood you can't
even tell if you're one of those guys or
you can't even tell people that story
can you just look like a [__] yeah yeah
I [__] up this dude I was holding his
baby and I've gone one two you got to
keep that story to yourself and you guys
those two are the biggest [__] I've
ever seen in my life like he literally
can't swing or even defend it so because
he's holding his daughter yeah guy came
with the sucker punch yeah on the side
and keeping behind it yeah what a puss
but the dad is also stupid - I weren't
even getting into shoot just leave the
[__] restaurant yeah like your
daughter's life is way more he's dead
that's of them yeah he let his own vevo
get in the way of everything he was a to
himself nobody's gonna hit me I feel
like he was drunk cuz he moved too slow
because I think immediately if I got hit
and someone's trying to grab my kid I'd
let them take the kid so I could handle
all he just got rocked
[Laughter]
[Music]
they feel so big how is the whole
restaurant hey why is the whole
restaurant [__] yeah that's what I'm
saying
were they all servers and [__] just like
everyone was working there the others
jumped is do you know what the dumb
thing is - they already knocked him out
and they kept hitting him as he was
already knocked out yeah he's already
done like well what point do you need a
serve like you got him you good yeah
what's going on here is there any
backstory I don't know why they want to
fight the only other information I know
is that the victim was airlifted to a
nearby hospital
oh he's sustained serious body injuries
well he was getting kneed in the head
and those guys got arrested there so
they actually got away for some time and
then the cops were looking for them but
now they found them I mean with the
camera footage you know they're probably
gonna go to jail for a little like some
attempted [__] yeah cuz that's like some
serious [__] yeah it does a little girl
yeah so they got charged with
first-degree assault
extreme and different second-degree
assault serious bodily injury and child
abuse and then the victim got a summons
for misdemeanor child abuse because he
put his daughter yeah yeah he stepped up
to them I don't know where he was behind
the counter well his daughter to control
their mouths and people just picking her
ass are you BBQ telling his story of
like how he like took on three guys dad
but didn't you peepee yourself real bad
and you also stinking yourself yes I
lost control my bowels honey one of my
friends um had a daughter right and he
just lost his job well dad I guess
you're a homeless person a job he could
tell me he was sober but laugh a little
[__] dick that video of the little
girls one of them she's like my daddy's
got a gold
oh yeah I'm gonna beat your goal - yeah
I remember when I was a kid we had a
friend who was like very very overweight
woman and like it was my mom's friend
and I remember we were driving one day
and my mom with something he came up
about her being fat or something and I
was like mom she's not fat and she's
like honey she's fat and that's why I am
the way so there you go I tried the
blade thing and my mom corrected me yeah
you tell like how it is young Steve
you're right I can't wait til Tiger gets
anti-aging either cuz I forgot
everything that Isaac said like I should
have been better and I kept a journal
cuz he would say the funniest things and
I could I just can't remember what we
just walk around blowing up the used
condoms oh yeah oh it's brand-new
however not seen that in the movie I
know right that's pretty [__] funny
I've never seen that movie you've seen
kids with dildos like when they go and
they come out with the [__] buzz
because you can't show sperm or
something in the movies is that why
Jenni yeah I used condom so there's
sperm in that is depends on the remember
Something About Mary they had sperm oh
yeah
they had a promotional campaign around
spur yeah I was like on her ear or was
somewhere order scary movie had so much
come it was ridiculous that was funny as
[__] a fountain her up to the ceiling
that was actually right Oh Cameron Diaz
yeah but this dude
horrible horrible parenting I really I'm
curious how or what causes entire
altercation me to forgive the whole
restaurant to hate you yeah it just look
like a pizza shop like hey man I step it
Bharani yeah yeah I can't fight if I
have like bomb ass food in front of me
that's the last thing I care about like
food first kid later there's no way it
was bomb ass food yeah
bad food makes me pretty angry though oh
for sure mmm-hmm oh I don't know their
pizza I don't know about their pizza
over there yeah because it's the East
Coast all the pizzas good it's hard for
me to tap into the danger zone if
there's children around it's weird but
you know to me like it's kind of I don't
know I'm not in a fight mode I probably
should I leave that place I don't go
there the danger zone oh I usually spend
my time walking and talking my way out
of the danger zone
that seems like school and shitty little
brawls nothing crazy that's right
there's supposed to be yeah I talked my
way out was that what's the one incident
you can remember talking your way out of
all the time I mean why did real-life
trolling videos like I was talking about
self out of like literally every single
days everyone would try to fight you
everyone try to find me because that was
the idea is that I try to piss people
off right people who deserve it would be
like [__] you mad and you were like 100%
I did this thing where I guy I would go
up to guys while they're like clearly
holding hands with girls and I would hit
on the girl while they're walking with
the guy maybe they'll who's this like
your gay friend like someone is your
brother like a friend like you're both
gay friend like whatever I would have
loved that dude I would have been laughs
yeah right that's what I you hope and a
lot of guys got frontal [__] and like
always this is disrespecting me and [__]
I saw that video that she was so [__]
funny because that kid was it was just
like one of those like but she's mo
Mexicans yeah I mean like this is my
woman you know and I kept hitting on her
I wouldn't stop I would not stop
everybody cuz a girl was cracking up
because she knew she knew it was like
she could tell and she had but she was
also talking about
hey chill chill chill and then he was
going crazy and he's this little kid to
you was you like half your size like you
would get demolished most people usually
are yeah but but the point was that I
could talk my way out of it and this
isn't like I'm not good bragging it's
just that it's just like you can if you
out crazy in them a little bit then
they're a little then they come down
immediately have you ever been in a
situation where someone that has already
started to kind of get physical and you
talked away out yeah so like the ones I
did this one where I had Nicky dressed
up like like a hooker yeah and she was
like sitting on a bench right and then
when guys came up to try to hit on her
or whatever I would I would step in and
I'd be like excuse me sir are you trying
to procure her services from this woman
like she like that well no I would like
come up like like hey are you trying to
procure her services from this woman
here like are you trying to pay her for
sex for sexual activity and then they're
like no and then she's like he gave me
20 bucks and said suck his dick I think
the guy's like what the [__] no I didn't
and then this one guy like he had like a
couple backpacks on or some [__] and he
was like yo [__] would and then
I I said some crazy [__] like two that
made him go like I will [__] eat your
dick base right exactly [__] how do you
start from the base if you say something
crazy you can see the switch in people's
heads like start the girl look like that
and that's what like violent crazy or
more like you ever had your balls tickle
before um it's usually something like
like I doubled down but it just depends
on the context of the situation like if
we're talking right now like like come
at me right now like with some [__] you
want to [__] die I'm ready to die I'm
like are you ready to die sir
I just meant it as a figure of speech
are you ready to die of old age sir
because you're gonna be in prison along
something on whatever the [__] this
depends on what what the scenario is
exactly that's exactly right so you're
just you're just trying to confuse them
enough where they're like oh I don't I
don't know what I'm doing I just want
you out of here did you pay your phone
bill I don't know actually
just stove on at home okay you know what
you distract me just enough there's an
arc to Atlantic to it is because I don't
know how to deal with confrontation and
I don't even like to Hawk and get myself
riled up because I don't know how to
exist in the middle I only know
exude a prompt peace or total rage
I don't like in the middle of like hey
hey hey you [__] annoying man bbbbbb
yeah get out of the way sucker ha ha
[Music]